ja so sehr wie sich hier ein schäfer
einen anschlag wieder kunst wünsche ich
mir eine pragmatische funktionierende
und wirksame energiepolitik ich glaube
das wird der lackmustest für die ampel
koalition in den nächsten monaten und
jahren denn der energiepreis schock ist
spürbar und ich habe keine ahnung wie
robert habeck masterplan für die
energiewende dazu führen könnte dass
vielleicht gerade um sozial
benachteiligte gruppen am ende strom und
heizung bezahlen können was längst zu
einer zweiten miete geworden ist also
hier brauchen wir sofort einen
entlastungs eine entlastung offensive
auf dem thema energiepreise und hier ist
die ampel gefordert sonst haben wir
irgendwann ein hartz4 für die grünen und
das bedeutet dann massenhafte
demonstrationen nicht gegen die korona
politik sondern gegen die energiepolitik
der bundesregierung
michael ich kann dich da nur
unterstützende dem was du gesagt hast
ich glaube auch es geht einmal um die
frage wie energie bezahlbar bleiben kann
vollkommen richtig die zweite frage ist
glaube ich wie deutschland es überhaupt
verhindert in eine energie armut
abzurutschen also die große frage
ausstieg aus der kernkraft bis ende
dieses jahres dann ausstieg aus der
kohlekraft bis ende zwanzig dreißig also
in einem von neun jahren und wenn wir
uns einmal nur mal anschauen wie viel
strom wir derzeit brauchen 530 terawatt
schon pro jahr irgendwie zahlen über 530
und es soll ja steigen dieser
stromverbrauch auf bis zu 700 30
terawattstunden 2030 also von 530 auf 37
ungefähr so jetzt nehmen wir aber
ungefähr die hälfte dessen was erzeugt
wird nämlich aus kohle und kernkraft
daraus 530 durch zwei sondern so bei 270
82 sollen aber jetzt auf 730 kommt das
heißt wir müssen ja von neun jahren
eigentlich den anteil der erneuerbaren
nicht nur verdoppeln sondern verzweifelt
um 200 prozent
steigern und das ist doch eine
herausforderung ich weiß nicht sie aus
der politik kommt was sie dazu sagen
aber ich halte das für schier unmöglich
das zu machen deswegen glaube ich droht
uns mit der klimapolitik die die ampel
plant ein absolutes debakel in
finanzieller hinsicht für die
bürgerinnen bürger für die firmen aber
dann auch mit der großen frage haben wir
noch energie und strom sicherheiten naja
da streitet sich natürlich die
wirtschaftlichkeit mit dem
wie
verhindern wir jetzt das
dass der klimawandel noch voranschreitet
aber ich glaube einfach selbst wenn wir
alle kollektiven selbstmord begehen und
unsere tiere gleich mit tüten werden wir
werden wir daran nichts ändern denn dazu
mit unseren 0,2 prozent hier in
deutschland wird es nicht gehen und ob
die jetzt wirklich die vorbildfunktion
geben wo dann die ganze welt drauf guckt
audi machen das richtig und so wie die
deutschen so machen wir es auch das
glaube ich eher nicht wir sollten
wirklich auf forschung setzen ganz klar
und dass auch die behördenwege sich
verkürzen weil das ist jetzt einfach so
windkrafträder ja bis die mal genehmigt
werden da ist ja alles vorbei und die
bevölkerung will auch keine
windkrafträder aus den bekannten grund
sehnlich schön aus vogelflug und
schatten die sich da bilden aber
vielleicht gibt es andere technologien
vielleicht kann man wirklich unter
unseren agrarflächen erdwärme erzeugen
und vielleicht gibt es andere
möglichkeiten die schneller gehen und
natürlich auch thorium reaktoren es
kommt jetzt aus china und das ist ja
verteufelt und reaktoren das an alle
gleich auch um himmels willen bloß nicht
die wollen wir doch alle abschaffen aber
vielleicht wäre das ja eine gute
übergangslösung
sie sollen jahr 2030
kommerzialisiert werden und auf den
markt kommen vielleicht sollte man die
bevölkerung und auch die grünen
davon überzeugen dass ist als
übergangslösung bis dann wirklich die
erneuerbare energie funktioniert
vielleicht wäre das inzwischen lösung
das problem ist ja stichwort
versorgungssicherheit also die
energiewende ist schon eine riesen
chance für uns wenn ich allein an den
mittelstand denke vor ein paar jahren
jetzt ist es ja nicht mehr durch corona
aber auf der hannover messe da sind
hallen voll mit deutscher
umwelttechnologie die wir weltweit
exportieren wie autos wie maschinen und
so weiter eine riesenchance das problem
ist nur wir müssen ehrlich bleiben wir
dürfen keine doppelmoral zeigen und
dürfen auch nicht doppelt ziemlich sein
also es kann nicht sein dass wir hier
aus kernkraft gehen aus kohle gehen
gaskraftwerke vilja wollen viele nicht
haben und dann importieren wir den strom
aus atomkraft aus frankreich und aus
kohle aus kohle aus tschechien das wäre
doppelt sich das ist uns mal in der
landwirtschaft passiert ich mich auch
nicht richtig wir hatten früher hier
käfige hühnerkäfigen die haben wir hier
verboten und jetzt kommen die eier die
wir essen die frühstückseier die kommt
deutschland aber alle eier die veredelt
sind zum beispiel den nudeln et cetera
ja kommen jetzt vor allem aus osteuropa
wo noch viel niedrigere
tierschutzstandards sind als bei uns
aber wir sagen kommt doch jetzt nicht
aus deutschland also uns geht es ja gut
das ist doppelt fündig das eine
doppelmoral und erwarte ich von der
politik auch von meiner partei dass man
hier den rücken gerade macht dass man
ehrlich ist weil die leute sind nicht
blöd die durchschauen das ja und
deswegen wirklich vorsicht an der
bahnsteigkante
das ist auch zum teil
schaufensterpolitik was weder betreiben
auch bei der braunkohle da hat man ja
gesagt 238 geht es raus die braunkohle
ist bereits in einem markt system drin
wo man einen preis bezahlen muss für die
umweltverschmutzung was richtig ist und
je teurer der preis desto mehr druck hat
man um in andere technologien zu gehen
das fall findet jetzt statt das heißt
selbst wenn die politik keinen beschluss
gefasst hätte wir müssen schon 2030 aus
wäre es 20 34 35 33 wir sind also ich
will sagen die menschen sind nicht blöd
ja die ja die haben sehr viel ahnung
auch über die energiewende die wollen
die energiewende aber mit den menschen
nicht gegen die menschen und auch
ehrlich sein und nicht hinterher die
atomkraft in folge ins heim gebracht
mich ja ich lese ja nicht nur sehr gerne
und sehr aufmerksam deren hauptstadt
wohin seine mediapro ja noch ganz viele
andere spannende medienprodukt und einen
zeit fand ich sehr spannend und zwar
habt ihr nämlich mal euch gefragt wie
viel ist ein deutscher bereit für das
klima aussehen und 62 prozent sagen
weniger als 50 euro pro monat da habe
ich schon geschluckt und mir gedacht
okay ich bin ja auch total ehrlich
gesagt bei ihnen herr lehmann hier darf
man ja auch als moderatorin seine
meinung sagen ich finde vielerlei von
der energiewende was wir plant völlig
skurril aber schaffen wir es vielleicht
einfach nicht anders diese zahl hat mich
schon zum nachdenken damals gebracht 2
und 2 62 prozent der deutschen sagen sie
würden weniger als 50 euro pro monat für
den klimawandel für den klimaschutz
ausgeben die positiv und das haben wir
glaube ich auch gerade gesagt frau gilt
ist ja was schaffen wir eigentlich was
bringen wir der welt wenn man
klimaschutz als auch multinationales
projekt ja sieht das schaffen wir
eigentlich mit einem euro den wir hier
noch in klimaschutz stecken wie viel
reduzieren wir eigentlich den co2
ausstoß beispielsweise oder könnte
dieser euro selbst wenn er aus
deutschland kommt also von deutschen
steuerzahlern möglicherweise andere
ländern einen viel größeren effekt
erzeugen da gibt's ja untersuchungen die
ganz klar sagen dass einsparen einer
tonne co2 sind deutschland mittlerweile
fast zehnmal so teuer wie beispielsweise
das einsparen einer tonne co2 in afrika
oder auf dem asiatischen kontinent das
bedeutet ich könnte mit einem aus
deutschland kommen den investierten euro
ich will gar nicht mehr sagen dass sie
anders dann bezahlen müssen man könnte
ja sagen aus deutschland kommend mit dem
ein euro viel mehr erreichen wenn ich
ihn gar nicht hier investiere in
klimaschutz sondern woanders und das
heißt wir könnten also beim faktor zehn
mit zehn euro die wir von hier woanders
investieren das gleiche erreichen zehn
euro muss man sich ja vorstellen ja nun
können wir natürlich erst unsere politik
für für uns in deutschland machen ich
weiß was du meinst du kann er ja in den
anderen ländern entscheiden was sie mit
unseren investierten euro ausmachen sagt
mir du musst es hier schaffen und ich
verstehe durchaus das ansinnen zu sagen
was uns vorreiter sein das ist nicht
ganz schlecht bei technologieoffenheit
bei einem möglichen neuen
geschäftsführer für deutschland ich
hätte nur gerne in einem wahnsinnigen im
nachbarort klima geht interessiert am
ende doch was in deutschland passiert
das weltklima aber die handlung die
technologie nur exportieren und dann
werden die besten gaskraftwerke oder die
schönsten wasserstoffanlagen irgendwie
im ausland gebaut ich war ja nicht ich
will die wände ja hier habe ich während
ich will sie funktionieren aber die
reduktion der effekt den ich habe der
ist möglicherweise mit dem dort
investierten euro mag sein ja aber das
mag dabei scheinen ja am ende die länder
dort vor ort ob sie die namen wir müssen
sie ja auch importieren also zb in
afrika und in länder mit vielen wüsten
erscheint vielmehr sonne und als bei uns
in deutschen das gibt es gibt auch
länder in denen viel mehr wind weht als
bei uns in deutschland und wenn wir also
ökostrom aus dem ausland importieren und
nicht nur kohle und kraft kernkraft
energie vielleicht wäre das auch die
möglichkeit dass wir ihnen eben unsere
forschung und unsere möglichkeiten
verkaufen anbieten lernen und dafür von
ihnen den ökostrom krach machen wir ja
wir machen grüne wasserstoff projekte
mit nordafrika ich glaube diese ganzen
technologiepartnerschaft mit einer
ländern machen wir trotzdem ist für mich
der punkt den haben sich angesprochen
der lindemann kriegen die grünen ist in
ihrer eigenen klientel durch dass wir
tatsächlich dieses land umbauen werden
und zwar sichtbar nicht nur wegen der
windkraftwerke sondern auch wegen
verpflichtungen für eigentümer für
hauseigentümer was sich in halbwegs
masterplan lese ist enorm wenn ich sehe
dass der durchschnittliche bestandene
der gebäude in deutschland ungefähr 80
er jahre ist und die alle nicht
energetisch saniert sind aber sich ein
60 jähriges paar vielleicht gar nicht
leisten kann dieses energetisch zu
sanieren weil sie noch nicht mal mehr
5000 euro dann noch investieren das
mitkriegen sie können auch noch gar
keine kreditanfrage er muss in seiner
eigenen klientel für die akzeptanz
sorgen und wir müssen schon scharf das
ist doch praktisch machen aber weil wir
mehr sagen es muss klappen und das sagen
die grünen auch mal so professor kämpfer
hat jetzt nicht verdächtigt dass sie
besonders ihrer partei nahesteht sondern
eher den grünen hat das ja mal
ausgerechnet um das 20 30 alles so recht
was robert habeck plan sagt sie alle
viereinhalb stunden müsste in
deutschland ein neues windrad ans netz
gehen alle viereinhalb stunden bedeutet
wir müssen jetzt sofort anfangen wir
wissen aber selbst in baden württemberg
grün regiert seit vielen vielen jahren
hat sich die zeit bis ein windrad dann
am ende gebaut werden kann
genehmigungsphase hat sich auf vier
jahre verkürzt vier jahre das heißt wenn
wir jetzt anfangen würden mit den ganzen
welt erneut der hallig ja auch ändern
und zwar soll er die ganzen gründe warum
kein windrad gebaut werden so minimiert
werden und er jetzt ganz schnell gehen
das muss man mit landwirtschaftsminister
und tierschutz ministry müsste mir
besprechen der eigentlich den greifvogel
und die kröte natürlich bewahren soll
das hauptthema wird sein
technologieoffenheit bei der
energiewende und auch beschleunigung und
versus artenschutz und auch da bin ich
wieder dabei dann müssen sich die grünen
in ihren eigenen reihen erst mal ehrlich
machen und in die versprechen sind mir
auf jeden fall ein bisschen zu
ambitioniert was da im plan steht ich
weiß wie sie sind also wenn man sind
planen schreibt dass die
genehmigungsverfahren halb jetzt werden
finde ich super ich glaube das würde
jeder unterstreichen aber wenn es dann
konkret wird dann tut sehr weh weil es
ja im eigenen garten ist jetzt mal bild
nicht gesprochen also muss ja nicht nur
die die windkraft ist ein beispiel oder
hat die bahninfrastruktur
jeder ist für die bahn der ausbau der
bahnstrecke von berlin nach münchen da
fahre ich jetzt vier stunden früher
brauchte sechs stunden hat 26 jahre
gedauert das geld war die ganze zeit da
aber dann gab es immer initiativen vor
ort wegen dieser sache nicht oder wegen
jener sache wenn wir 26 jahre für so
eine blöde oder eine gute bahn strecke
genutzt die auch brauchen wie sollen wir
dann die energiewende schaffen
jetzt haben wir köln/berlin dasselbe
thema da fahren wir sechs stunden mit
dem ic war und seit zehn jahren
diskutiert darüber dass wir einen haben
vielleicht nicht die die ics auseinander
koppeln sondern vielleicht eine
ersatzstrecke das ist ein wahnsinniges
genau ist nur die erwartungshaltung ist
groß wobei habeck verspricht viel und
die enttäuschung kann sehr großen und
der widerstand im volk der punkt ist
glaube ich und den sinn wir in unserer
runde auch wir haben irgendwie nicht den
doppelten boden was machen wir
eigentlich wenn es nicht klappt ja über
diese um diese frage drückt sich
eigentlich jeder herum es wird ja und
heißen muss dass es klappt ist es los
und ja nur stehe ich es muss klar ein
imposant aber was ist daran jeder die
gleiche doppelt ziemlich kazuki bei den
käfigen auch aber dass das das jährigen
ehrlich aber man ganz einfacher
vorschlag wirklich ganz einfach warum
ist der sprit teurer geworden es gibt
tausend gründe aber ein grund ist man
muss den co2 preis ist eine co2 abgabe
und dann gibt es milliarden die werden
jedes jahr angesammelt und diese
milliarden sollte man eins zu eins an
die verbraucher zurückgeben weil der die
idee ist ja ich mache sprit teurer
damit die firmen innovativer werden
damit ich mir überlege damit der
bürgermeister mit druck hat vielleicht
übrigens auszubauen und so weiter aber
das geld gehört doch den menschen das
muss eins zu eins zurück stattdessen
wird jetzt ein teil wieder
quersubventioniert in irgendwelche
anderen dinge das wäre mal eine
forderung finde ich dies einfach und es
käme zurück den gleichen fehler haben
uns bei der rente gemacht da sind auch
versicherungsfremde leistungen die gar
nichts mit der rente zu tun mit den
beiträgen ja über die beiträge bezahlt
worden und die ihnen die beiträge
bezahlt haben haben dann hinterher
weniger rente bekommen viel zu
kompliziert ich würde noch ich würde sie
sind journalist
nein aber ich würde einfach an die neuen
abgaben rangehen 40 prozent der roman
sind steuern und abgaben das kann die
politik selbst entscheiden wie sie den
strompreis reguliert trotz der ganzen
internationalen verwerfungen die es auch
bei den gaspreisen gibt verstehen also
warum steuer rund 65 fordern sofort
gärtner fall löst das problem am ende
nein aber es ist ja dass ich vielleicht
schon haben die machbar der erst jetzt
machbar musst du jetzt machen trotzdem
die anderen dinge machen